you will always get a better product
when the writer comes with his vision
the director comes with a contrary
vision the actors come from with their
vision and everybody's kind of clashing
it's a soup it's a soup and then you
fight and you compromise you you kind of
know this what I want to do try this and
when you all have a different point of
view a lot of times that's when magic
happens what's and also your writing
with podcasting to so many people I love
meetings with people in the video dude
we're gonna put this guy and this guy
yeah this could be the biggest podcast
Erica's this guy is this many followers
yeah this guy has this many polish he
thinks this that this guy thinks is IO
are they friends here's no idea do they
know each other he's not saying it
doesn't work like oh we're gonna take a
previous fighter and kameen and put them
together it's fine the kid doesn't work
like that doesn't work does not work
like you just can't know he doesn't
it's a weird chemistry can I replace
Brian and you have a bigger show yeah
what stuff well no that's not what hey
hold on hold on but this restaurant for
breakfast um we didn't eat the night
before we got in late we're starving and
this is our first meal we sit down and I
ask the lady I go what like what should
we order not from here you're everyone
told to come to this restaurant what
should we order just we're known for our
chicken and waffles and biscuits and
gravy enjoy yours I'll take both those I
went what did you say I would you listen
we're here we got to try them like but
no we don't we don't that's why we're
both thick as [ __ ] we don't have to eat
at all so we did and it's delicious my
son has my daughter has the natural gene
that I have right where a little bit is
just fine like I can eat half a piece of
chalk I had that my son my son will eat
what you put in front of him like if
it's a giant piece of cake he'll stuff
at all in his mouth my son's the same
it's nuts I'm the same with like yeah
last night
I was good all day well I got home I
want to get the Black Lung out so I rode
the bike for an hour burned a thousand
calories didn't ET fasted - two o'clock
after my workout and I'm like all right
I have a nice shake for lunch I'm like
you know I'm gonna do no car from
getting shaped my supposed to come out
with me shred city's gonna be great I
have some nice steak filet
cook that again no carbs just salted
meat and then
nine o'clock like I get a sweet tooth
mmm about five missing I'm like I get
sweet teeth so I'm gonna need to go to
the salt and strong they're in the
freezer and just try it out you got it
no we got a couple scoops that's all
dude I think I'm should take one scoop
I'll be good yeah I see no I'm watching
[ __ ] Bill Clinton get balls deep in
girls and I'm halfway through this
[ __ ] tub yeah and then next I know
part one ends part two strikes up I
can't not not eat the rest of it not and
watch Bill wise ass off so I finished it
you gotta eat it all there's a woman I
woke up sworn burned it off I think yeah
and the sweat from this sauna we're in
right now
it's awesome what dude what dude besides
me have not as father time not touched
Josh wolf Idris Elba yeah well yeah seal
seal thank you seal does not age hey
what black guys what non black guys mmm
it's father Tom Cruise Tom Cruise is
done well needles have touched his face
like well his eyes are looking a little
bit like mine they're what the eyes give
you know Hubbard touched him yeah the
eyes on Donner man kind of like they
could they start to droop you see he's
not doing the Jack Reacher oh you know
you know he's better-looking than you I
think they made mr. Reeves
no canoe he's got some Asian in him he's
Samoan I think right or Hawaii
Indonesian I think I saw Matt Starbucks
and he is a fine yes yes he's also not
all mall no he's like six Jamin on his
motorcycle you goddamn snack yeah man
yeah he looked good now he's a
good-looking guy if I if if you would
came into no car like a Porsche um I
would talk shop with him him or second I
don't know [ __ ] about it
so my bridesman cool bike man ya know
he's a he's a striking man he's always
been a very good-looking guy I would
yeah he is crazy rich too oh yeah
doesn't make a bad movie is arrested
because he he said he was gonna drop a
bomb and they actually thought it was a
terrorist thing when he was talking
about taking a [ __ ] at a chicken
restaurant wait who did he say he's
gonna use says staff I mean I'm gonna
drop bombs in here I'm gonna
drop a bomb in the bathroom I mean the
staff is so dumb to report him on this
no but I guess the family there's a
chance that he really did say that he
wanted to come a bathroom yeah if we
know what that means but says emploice
no police said y'all bout to close right
now because I'm going to get a bomb
that's the importance and blow this
place yeah you know bomb that stuff he
said yeah I guess is he probably said
I'm gonna blow up the bathroom and by
the way didn't have any bombs so what's
not you know when the cops tracked down
Posey claimed it was a giant mr. stern I
explained he told staffers he's going to
blow the bathroom up meaning he was
gonna poop his brains out cops didn't
buy what Posey was selling rest he's
accused of facing two counts of
communicating false information of
planned arson give me a [ __ ] break
he was gonna poop his brains huh that
clothes that you gotta close this place
down imma take a [ __ ] I've said that
I've said that I've never said that
exact thing I've said to the staff took
a state I'd say everyone shut down let
me drop bomb well he might have been
just a [ __ ] you know being silly and
funny but you know he's not a terrorist
and does he have bombs uh yeah that's
really I don't think he needs to go to
prison no that's not arrest him I got
other things to worry
yeah hey man take a [ __ ] when you go to
Arizona State when you go and you see
your yeah FSU and you go to those places
it's literally like murderers row when
it comes to women you're done Hugh you
not studying high school is the top five
and number one for multiple years for
biggest party school in the u.s. yeah
correct me if I'm wrong maybe I'm wrong
maybe wrong let me ask you a question if
when you're a do you want a fleet I'm
just I don't know when you're a d1
athlete some of those girls some of
those girls who are now 18 19 20 21
feeling their oats sure and fully
developed women sure and on their own
for the first time and also separated
from the herd by herd I mean they're
family mommy's not there anymore and
they're carnivorous daddy's here no well
daddy's here now and he's young as [ __ ]
- right so doesn't like condom no as my
hold on when I spread bad that what Pepe
should wear arledge but if you wear
college calling
okay your experiment all right so what's
on your dick what's up mom all right
well I understand that alcohol flowing
but some of those girls like an athlete
a d1 level athlete me I am I is that am
I
yeah I'd make one small correction
graduate them there we said some yes I'd
say oh and that's a thing now when you
go to another school like Harvard or
Williams or Harvard you me all right
you're still a little bit weird nephews
going you're dealing with three warlocks
and very smart people who probably put
less emphasis on their look now I don't
want say all of them have flat asses but
I'd say 99.9% of smart women this world
have a flat ass
really Oh name of valedictorian with a
fat ass I don't know yeah I don't either
bro they're not out there God doesn't
work that I don't know if you have a fat
ass thing all right you who want a fat
ass front online brains back in line
really science I haven't seen that I
haven't seen any of that but I don't
have a set of tits on him every now and
then double flapjacks
now that I have Invisalign let me see I
notice everybody's teeth real quick he
has a nose famous guy animal handled er
no I don't they're real Tarzan or
something no all right so he has the
craziest veneer things is your Wow
African elephants teeth look great but
they look so fake though don't they yeah
again it's like girls faked it we all
know they're fake but they very
appealing yeah yeah and you can actually
get Lanier's that look you can yeah the
right guy all right no no here's look
like he looks like the mask yeah
just Robin's teeth somewhere you know by
the way Rodan could give a [ __ ] but
still don't don't try come rub now nah
he's all up in his goddamn back up
Sparky um maybe just Google Joe Rogan
friggin teeth I don't know if you need
Rogan teeth you can just zoom in oh
there you go
all right yeah I'll say when you're
looking down at them know they'll even
they're not great listen no one in this
room besides cats win an award for it to
me I have good teeth now you do not have
good teeth whoever's telling that it's
full of [ __ ] actually I told row gum get
veneers and he was like whatever bro
look at that funny how you can how the
algorithm is so good and so quick Kathy
oh that's amazing
who is the best teeth that we know
they're veneers bro
everyone just D'Elia daliyah has good
teeth probably sometimes you can't see
open ears cuz their lips sometimes you
don't know till Jesus Christ when this
here's super who those are good teeth
yeah yeah there you go I've never looked
at Theo's teeth that can't be good being
a redneck it's just on their DNA most
people have like people do people my
family's all English so dirty
my grandma's teeth she got all her teeth
removed when she was like 24 yeah some
people have their seams you say you know
what [ __ ] it
I think Theo probably had braces so his
teeth look good I don't think so
they look way too good teeth I'll have
to see him I know who he's trying to
fool there that he's happy though yeah
they look really good
that looks like a killer if you like hey
Theo you skip paid to do it looks like a
point it when you see my back rip I pull
myself up like a champ like a chimp
through 30 times fast while talking to
you why wouldn't I give that to you as
it's a gets a gift it's a gift